You know, whenever I teach my workshops...
...on stage fright and how to do seminars and how to get rid of fear of public speaking,...
...inevitably someone asks the question, "What should I do if I'm in front of people..."
"...and I have a panic attack?"
If you have a sudden attack of stage fright, your nervous system is going into stressed out mode.
You need a way to be able to calm down fast.
Here's a little known secret that works every time.
To stop a sudden attack of stage fright, all you have to do is defocus your eyes.
You can learn to talk with your eyes defocused...
...by practicing talking with your hands at the sides of your head...
...and visually, only pay attention to your hands.
After a while, you can easily get used to talking with your eyes defocused.
It's simple and easy to do.
Is it really that easy to stop an attack of stage fright in its tracks?
It really is, and if you want more tools and tips and techniques, just go to seminaracademy.com.